let's go next to how about uh Dan from
California Dan from California welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
uh hi David uh I I do a lot of debates
and discussions on my YouTube channel
I've done some with Sam Cedar and I was
wondering if you would ever be up for a
long form debate I'm a big Iron ran fan
so uh that's the perspective I'm coming
from what would the debate be about
maybe about politics or ethics I do
those topics a lot capitalism or egoism
yeah I mean maybe you know I'm really
limiting my appearances elsewhere just
because I'm so busy and to be totally
honest I you might your channel might
have five million followers I don't know
and this is not how I base my decisions
but very often there's like very little
upside and it just it dominates my
schedule you know I want to have as
clear as schedule as possible so like
maybe the way to request that would be
to email in
okay it might make a difference if I
offered to pay uh no it really wouldn't
okay yeah I mean like how much would it
be worth to you I don't know maybe it
should
I don't know man like a hundred bucks
for that give me no no I'm kidding I'm
kidding around no it it would not make a
difference unless the amount was way
higher Dan please
okay no I'm kidding around I I might do
it but I'm really I'm really Limited in
what I'm doing just because I'm so busy
what is what would be your biggest gripe
with my perspective I guess is my first
question
I guess one fundamental issue which
probably underlies political issues is
your ethics so I don't know what your
view in ethics is but do you think
people have a moral rights to live for
their own sake
that would be one key question or should
they be forced to sacrifice for other
people yeah see this is this is another
reason why I tend not to do these sorts
of debates I exist in a place where I
find many of those questions do people
have a right to live for themselves or
should they be forced to sacrifice for
others well the the first question is
what kinds of societies do we even
believe are best or or advisable and one
of the unfortunate not maybe unfortunate
but like when I hear that question Dan
and this is why these often end up being
philosophical black holes one of the
biggest things when I hear that question
is
if we start from the point that we have
societies of more than 150 people quite
frankly and more than a thousand right
the US has 330 million people
it almost seems not super relevant
whether I think that in some theoretical
context we have a quote right to live
for ourselves or should be quote forced
to live for others if we want to be in
this type of society we are going to
centralize some aspects of society and
the economy while hopefully finding a
balance that still allows people
reasonable amounts of self-determination
if that if for me I start there because
this is the society I live in and if I
don't like that I would then look at
okay maybe I need to find a different
Society where the dichotomy you raise is
actually feasible it's less interesting
to just abstractly discuss the dichotomy
you bring up I don't think we get much
out of it if that's fair
I think taxes you know that exists in
our society so we all have to deal with
that if that's a case where I would say
we're forced to sacrifice what we would
choose to do with our own money for the
sake of other people so I think it is
very relevant too are we though I mean
on taxes you're not forced to work right
like you could choose not to work
yeah but if you do choose to work you're
forced to give away some of your
earnings to other people but you said
you said if you choose to what you did
say if you choose to work right choose
is different than Force you acknowledge
that
yes okay I agree and if you don't like
the tax structure of the United States
you could look to go to a different
place I understand it's difficult to
stop paying taxes to the United States
but there are different conventions you
could renounce your citizenship Etc like
you agree that you could also kind of
take your take your toys and leave to
some degree
as a right to put you in that kind of
position the government's rights tax I
don't think it has a right to tax it
only has rights that are delegated to it
by the citizens but the citizens
themselves don't have a right to coerce
others so they can't delegate the right
to curse others to the government okay
so basically it's like you're kind of
like a standard utopian libertarian it
sounds like
I'm not a utilitarian I'm an objectivist
Utopia utopian
all right well it's all very interesting
Dan listen if people hear this and think
it would be interesting for me to do
three hours on this let me know and then
I'll do Dan's show and Dan you can email
in and give me more info okay
all right thanks David appreciate it
there goes Dan and iron Rand fan and
listen we'll look into it it's just not
usually like the best use of anybody's
time that's been that's been my
experience which is why I kind of tend
to tend not to do it